said honey i can work a nine to five i
won't be thrilled to do it but if that's
the lifestyle you want
we can do that
or you can allow me to kind of grind for
a year or two see if i can make
something more of myself
i'll be more fulfilled that way but it
will require a little bit of sacrifice
on these first couple of years of
marriage
is it possible to grow a youtube channel
beyond just you what are the steps from
going from a nobody to a somebody who
can help thousands of people every
single day through free content and
online courses we're going to be
breaking down that and so much more in
today's interview with entrepreneur and
content creator parker wolbeck
my name is heather torres and i'm the
host of the think media podcast the
number one podcast to help you grow your
influence on youtube and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
income online business and that's what
we're breaking down today that piece
about building the online business here
at think media we want to help you grow
your youtube channel but that really is
just step one ultimately we want you to
be creating an entire online business
now if you're just getting started you
might think heather that is very
intimidating but we have so many
resources and tools to help you on this
journey and one of those resources is
actually the partner of today's podcast
thinkific whether you have a channel
about cooking guitar teaching online
business or fitness youtube creators
just like you are sharing something in
common the desire to reach more viewers
and build a bigger impact without
trading their time for money but how do
you do that by creating an online course
through the platform
thinkific more than 50 000 course
graders have already used thinkific to
build their revenue to educate students
worldwide you can get started today by
going to
createwiththink.com and start your
online course now in today's episode
we're diving in with parker wallback
entrepreneur and content creator who
started as a nobody and has now created
an empire online this is such an
encouraging interview because he talks
about how he went from giving his
services away for free to building a
team of creators who are generating
multiple seven figures i'm excited for
you to dive into this and we'll discuss
it after the featured interview
[Music]
today you know you've got over 400 000
followers on instagram and uh you've
worked with brands like hyundai uh cars
lg huawei canon um you know it
built a seven-figure plus per year
course business all this different kind
of stuff um but you've really gone
through
the steps you've you've built up an
expertise you've built up a skill when
did you get into video in the first
place and originally become
the full-time filmmaker himself
yeah so first of all i just want to echo
exactly what you said everybody that is
trying to youtube i tell every single
one of them you need to create your own
digital product and sell it take
advantage of the traffic you're
generating
and create your own product i mean it's
just it's a smart business move to make
if you're going to spend all this time
you know generating traffic on a youtube
channel package something that you can
sell
and selling knowledge is is always a
safe bet and something that you and i
have both proven can be very a very
lucrative successful business model but
i i started um
on the video side of things
i started for real hitting the ground
about 10 years ago i was doing summer
sales knocking doors selling directv and
about a month of that and i knew that
that wasn't the life i wanted to live i
always wanted to get in the video but
didn't really know how to get started um
so i quit my summer sales job midsummer
came home
used all the money i'd made there and
bought my first starter camera and a
laptop
and just started watching youtube videos
and trying to teach myself figuring out
if i could do it and that's when i came
across devin supertramp's youtube
channel and saw all of his behind the
scenes saw what he was doing and saw hey
you actually can make money with video
and he was one of the first making money
on youtube as well and so i just kind of
started following
his pattern and doing what he was doing
and then luck would have it about six
months into just dabbling in video
devon posted on social media saying hey
i need somebody who has arms that look
like this because i got to redo some
shots and he needed basically an arm
model and so i sent a picture of my arms
and he
messaged me back and said hey perfect
can you be in provo tomorrow and i'm
like absolutely so i got to meet my idol
at the time and was super stoked to work
with him and we just kind of hit it off
and i offered my services for free said
hey i'm looking to grow in the video
world would love to come shadow you do
some free work edit for free so i worked
for devon for free for probably two or
three months before he finally was like
okay this guy adds some value to me and
he hired me on full time and i traveled
the world with devin for about three
years and at some point got burnt out of
it wanted to start a family and uh i
mentioned to him the idea of starting a
course
and he wasn't really about it he wanted
to stick to what he was doing with his
youtube stuff so i quit
and started building full-time filmmaker
i i recognized a lot of people asking me
questions
i had built somewhat of a following
because of the runoff of devon's
subscribers
and uh people were asking me hey how did
you get started in this how do you how
do you get these these colors how do you
get smooth shots and i just saw the
potential i'm like there is a demand
there's a need people are asking
questions about this and so i might as
well cash in and figure out how to
monetize all those questions and so
that's what started the building a
full-time filmmaker and what year was
that that you transitioned with devin
and started to build out the course
yeah so i worked with devin from about
2013 to 2015 2015 i quit the month i got
married
and spent about nine months building
full-time filmmaker basically unemployed
i was also on the site building my own
video production company while building
full-time filmmakers so just burning the
candle at both ends uh that first year
of marriage and that was in 2015 2016 we
launched full-time filmmakers so it's
been about five years now that we've
been running full-time filmmaker and so
if we go a little bit deeper into that
season your
transitioning out of um the your main
source of income which was uh you know
creating that content now you're
building an online course unemployed uh
self-employed and when you say we was it
mainly you do was was now your wife
helping you or or who was working on
that or were you working that out by
yourself and
yeah
yeah i say we because i feel like
in order to succeed
i think in in at any
in any entrepreneurial
way you kind of have to have the support
of your significant other because
there's a lot of sacrifice that goes
into that on both ends
if i'm going to work 12-hour days which
sometimes is necessary in order to
launch a business
uh your wife has to kind of be in on
that and be like okay yeah i am willing
to sacrifice some weekends and sacrifice
some nights together knowing that you're
trying to build this to secure ourselves
a future
and we kind of made a pact when we first
got married i said honey i can work a
nine to five i won't be thrilled to do
it but if that's the lifestyle you want
we can do that
or you can allow me to kind of grind for
a year or two see if i can make
something more of myself
i'll be more fulfilled that way but it
will require a little bit of sacrifice
on these first couple years of marriage
and so i say we because she was um very
supportive of that but mostly it was me
doing it on my own just asking my
friends to come in and be my subject and
so uh it was a lot of a lot of me
filming and editing myself in my at the
time basement apartment
and uh it was it's a grind and it people
see now the success and the money and
the subscribers they see all that
but they don't see the first nine months
where we were scraping by the day i
launched full-time filmmaker had 500 to
my name had whittled down all my savings
investing in this business idea and and
that kind of sacrifice is kind of what
it takes um
to be able to be successful at a high
level but those who are willing to put
in the work ethic and sacrifice a little
bit of fun time or travel time or
vacation time or whatever to to save up
your your money and devote your time
into building something now sacrificing
now so that you can have something for
later um it's just kind of what it takes
i think
that's so powerful and you um as you're
in that that time you're shooting the
videos yourself you did your own course
outline you're sometimes having friends
be the subjects
um where did you
upload and host that original course and
uh what was sort of the technical side
of it
yeah so i should give credit to a good
buddy of mine chris newman when i quit
devin supertramp
he called me up the week or so after and
said hey man you need to build a course
and i'm like well i don't i don't know
man it's like trust me man i have a
drone course i've been teaching people
how to drone
it's great money it's really awesome and
it's like ah maybe i don't know and he
just kept telling me every week and
finally when we come like all right i'll
give it a shot and so chris convinced me
to start it and then i basically just
followed chris as my mentor he had set
up his course on thinkific so that's
what i used he used mail actually he was
using aweber at the time for for
emailing that was the one software i did
mailchimp different than him but i
basically followed his pattern and
that's another thing i tell people too
is find a mentor find somebody who's
already paved the path and done it
successfully learn from their mistakes
cut your learning learning curve in half
so that you're not just you know
guessing but figure out okay so and so
did this and it's worked so let's do
something similar to that it doesn't
have to be verbatim but but do do find a
mentor that's one of the biggest pieces
of advice i could give to people is find
a sean find a parker who's who's been
successful and look at how they built
their site look at what hosting sites
they're using and if it's worked there
it can probably work for you too but
yeah thinkifics where i started
i started uploading videos to there it
was a great software worked fine
about a year and a half in i switched
over to teachable uh they just had a few
different features that i liked and then
just recently a few months ago we
switched to kajabi so we've kind of been
all over the map and i tell people it
doesn't really matter which site you use
i think they're all
they're all great and we've proven that
with any of them we can make seven
figures a year so it's not really about
the software just pick one that fits
your needs has the features you like
best
and then you
work for nine months you hustle you
build it you're down to 500
left when when you launch it how do you
launch it and market the course when you
first come out with full-time filmmaker
1.0
yeah so i read this awesome book by jeff
walker called
i think it's just called launch um
but basically he he tells you how to
launch anything digitally online any
digital product how to launch and he he
gives you know mental triggers like
create anticipation and how to do a
pre-launch and so he gives a lot of
awesome tips and i basically just
followed the book verbatim and didn't
really know what i was doing but uh
thought he had some good ideas and so
about a week or two before i was ready
to launch i wasn't actually ready i was
still
you know tighten up all the loose ends
but about a week or two before i just
started putting out
contents to my following at the time i
had maybe 30 000 instagram followers and
maybe 8 000 youtube subscribers so not a
huge following but significant enough
and
and uh
put started putting out content saying
hey i'm building a course um if you'd
like to
[Music]
be notified when we launch which will be
at the time i think it was april 6 i was
launching in about march 20th i started
sending emails saying hey sign up for my
my live webinar where i'm going to
launch this so i started collecting
emails at this point for this launch
event this what this live webinar where
i would get it where i was going to be
i think i i launched with i was giving
away five glidecams to the to the first
hundred people who sign up for my course
you'd be entered to win one of five
glidecam so i i used some of these
tactics marketing tactics to kind of get
people excited about this launch event
and uh built up about 1500
um people on my on my mailing list
that were subscribed to
my email list to to go to this live
webinar
and about every three days i'd send out
a piece of content just something a
little teaser hey this is what the
course is going to be like so for about
10 days send them content every three
days and then the day of i said all
right
here's the live webinar link come on at
this time
and i think we got
three or 400 people of those 1500
to actually watch that live event
and it was about an hour long um i
basically just said all right here's
what i've been doing the last nine
months here's why i think you should buy
it here's the perks here's what it
covers and then i opened the shopping
cart and said all right it's now
available the first 100 people to join
will be entered to win five gl one of
five glidecams and
and that first
i think yeah that first hour
we did i can't remember the exact
numbers but it was around 40 grand
in sales in that first hour and my wife
is next to me in the background like
just like so excited and you know we had
gone from
nothing in the bank account to suddenly
oh it paid off and it was just like we
didn't know if it would pay off and it
did right in that first hour so it was a
a pretty fun launch event for us
yeah that's incredible and you know
success leaves clues uh jeff walker is a
legend in the space that book actually
just now has a second edition it just
was relaunched with some new content and
uh
podcast listeners of course there'll be
a ton of resources in the show notes
today but definitely we recommend that
one when you think about launching your
digital product but that's so powerful
because you put it out and you also it's
encouraging to hear
your results on that first launch but
you didn't try to make up the path on
your own i mean that's why you help
people today
you learn from your mentor you learn
from jeff walker you uh you took the
time to put in the work and do the steps
and man forty thousand dollars comes in
and and gets you now move in with
full-time filmmaker i'm curious
who did you um when did you hire your
first person i mean today this thing has
grown and you've got help what was the
journey of the team being built up and
how did you think about okay
uh how do i now do customer service or
fulfillment or how quickly did you need
help with the speed of growth at
full-time filmmaker
yeah so that launch
week the launch day we did about 40
grand by the end of the week i had an
opening and a closing so there was a
launch sequence
one week you get 50 off at the end of
that week we did around 100 grand for
the launch week and after that i
honestly
took a back seat with the core stuff
and started
focusing back on video production which
thinking back now i'm like that was
stupid like i had this awesome
opportunity i just launched and i went
immediately back into
doing trading time for money and working
for clients but it's hard to say no it's
hard to stop doing what you were doing
before and i still have people asking
hey can you come film this and it's just
hard to say no when it's comfortable
it's money it's there
and so i kind of stopped doing full-time
filmmaker for about four months after
the launch and just kind of let the
launch settle down and made sure that
people liked it and spent some time
building it a little bit more from the
feedback i was getting from students
and then at that point it was like how
do i keep selling this because it wasn't
really selling at that point because i
wasn't really marketing and advertising
it and that's when i started figuring
out how to run facebook and youtube ads
or excuse me at the time just facebook
ads
and uh so that's when i was thinking
okay i gotta hire somebody i don't i
don't know how to do social media ads
and so i hired a buddy of mine dallin
wright
uh just paid him retainer like a
thousand bucks a month or something said
hey help me figure out this facebook ad
stuff
and uh so he you know he'd work
part-time for me trying to dabble in my
in my facebook ads and it was enough he
figured out enough to kind of help me
get going and get off the ground and
launch some facebook ads and then i
started doing live webinars every week
and
and uh but it wasn't i couldn't afford
to pay him enough i wasn't generating
enough money to really bring him on full
time and so he had to leave and go do
something else full-time but he helped
me enough to to get going
and then about
oh i'd probably say maybe six months in
to running ads and about a year into
full-time launching full-time filmmaker
i started generating enough revenue and
having enough customer service and stuff
that i was like okay i need some help
this is a little bit overwhelming
so i hired on one of my full-time
filmmaker students actually who i
thought was really talented as as
basically an editor and to help with
some customer service stuff
he had bigger ambitions to travel the
world and didn't really think that we'd
be just you know editing all day and
doing customer service so he only lasted
about six months and then after that i
hired jake weisler who is still with me
today so about a year and a half in i'd
say maybe two years in i i hired my
first like full-time employee in jake
weisler
that's a cool timeline to hear and uh
just the nature of entrepreneurship um
you know working with some people
solving problems today finding that
synergy and uh building team person by
person and not even two years until
until the full-time person it reminds me
of heather taurus on the think media
team when we were just starting
she wore for free on performance based
of something that didn't exist yet it
was actually our first online course and
it was like you can have this percentage
of sales the course doesn't even exist
yet and so let's build it together let's
see how that goes and we she's an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur in her own
right that was like
i actually believe this will do well so
i'm taking risk with you um and
per you know team member by team member
today
um what does the team look like has it
has it grown i assume more and you have
course creator pro right and and and
then
film like you've got a premium where
people can get access to a lot of micro
courses on real estate film production
and smartphone creation whatnot so it
definitely has gotten more and more
complex is it all under one um umbrella
and and these different niches or or
what does the company look like today
yeah so
when jake came on and i always tell
people this because i think it's
significant to understand i always tell
people
focus on your highest value activities
and delegate out your lower value
activities and for me at the time that
was editing that was customer service
and
and so
when you find yourself in a position
where you're feeling overwhelmed doing a
lot of things and you have enough money
to pay somebody to do something
absolutely do it
and uh for me that was jake taking over
a lot of that lower end lower value
activities
and that allowed me to spend my more of
my time creating more youtube content uh
putting out more facebook ads doing the
higher value activities that were going
to bring in more money i now have the
infrastructure and the manpower to
handle the higher traffic and the higher
revenues coming in with with jake being
there and i'd say within three or four
months we doubled revenue from the time
that i hired jacob i was probably doing
oh i don't know
50 to 100 grand a month before him and
doubled
to 150 to 200 grand a month once i
brought jake on within a few months it
was very apparent that you know if i'm
putting a lot more of my time into
things that make the company money then
we can make a lot more money and so um
that first hire was super important to
the growth of our business and within
just a few months we started recognizing
okay we need even more help good because
we doubled overnight
and so
hired on some more customer service and
i always tell every employee that comes
to work for me
um
that you know sky's the limit you can
grow as much or as little as you want
here you can take over the business
completely if that's how talented you
are and i would love that um and so jake
kind of grew you know started on the
bottom doing customer service the grunge
work grew into where he's at now which
is a co-creator on the youtube channel
doing solo videos for our youtube
audience and he's created entire mini
courses inside of our full-time
filmmaker product and so
uh jake's been an awesome value-add to
the company and uh landon by the way was
our second i guess
content creator that came on and those
two kind of helped shape what would be
potentially the future of full-time
filmmakers uh brand and face
and then we have
a few customer service people we have
now behind the scenes shooters we have
editors we have
uh kind of overall
managers of the team so i think we're up
to seven or eight um
members of our team now
and it was about i think 2018 or 2019
so full-time filmmaker have been running
for about three years
and my brother dakota
approached me wanting to do something
together i had always been wanting to
create another course another business
entirely called course creator pro that
teaches people how to build what i built
with full-time filmmaker
and but i didn't have time for i was
just too time too consumed with uh
running full-time filmmaker and so i i
told the code i said hey i have this
business idea but i i can create the
content but i'll need you to edit all
the videos together and basically run
the business once it's up and running
i'll split it with you 50 50 if you want
to go in on it and so dakota then
invested a year of his life into helping
me build course creator pro
and we launched that i think in 2019
and uh that's that's done very well as
as well it's probably a a fourth the
size of uh revenue success as full-time
filmmaker it's a different i would say
smaller
market but
it's it's done really well as well but
that's
an entirely separate entity from
full-time filmmaker and that has
uh you know two or three of its own
employees so those specifically are kind
of separated full-time filmmaker course
creator pro two different businesses
that we've built there
and i don't have a ton to do with course
creator pro um i probably spend ten
percent of my time there and more around
you know eighty percent of my time in
full-time filmmaker
but uh
yeah that's that's kind of the within
full-time filmmaker all those mini
courses you see real estate weddings
commercial those are all just courses
within the package of full-time
filmmaker it's an amazing story and one
thing i kind of want to drill down on is
some of these uh
people close to you that you've you've
co-launched a business now together you
have other content creators on the
channel i mean you and i having this
conversation is is unique there's
certainly other examples on youtube
where there's kind of like teams of
people doing things besides solo
creators doing things and today on think
media we have uh nolan molt and omar el
takori uh creating content on the main
channel heather taurus has got her own
show
and co-hosts our podcast and tony's
creating content we're actually in that
kind of
team uh you know brand building um you
know it's a little bit different than
just being a youtuber kind of idea um
but i'm sure for those that are maybe
um wondering man that that seems like
it'd be super out of reach and like do
you just find somebody that's a stranger
i know from our perspective
a lot of these relationships have taken
years heather taurus and i've known
ourselves each other for five years but
omar and i have known each other for 10
years and we were on a church staff
together some of these what's your
philosophy in building out other
co-creators that are on the channel with
you and that's a family member so if you
have you found that when it comes to
building a team trust is everything
what's some of your you know thoughts
for somebody else that's like i don't
know about trusting people or hiring
people and like i would like to do that
but uh what what are your thoughts on on
building that really shared platform
type of business and those kind of
partnerships
yeah first of all i think that's super
awesome that you guys have expanded out
your creator lineup as well
there's different ways to go about it
but i think we're pretty similar minded
business-wise where running youtube
channel is not easy running a course is
not easy and having to be the solo face
of it there's a lot of pressure on you
and you just don't have as much
time and life freedom when when that is
the case and so i wanted a different
lifestyle and so that's why i wanted to
bring on other creators and so um you
know some people like being the solo
artist of their of their business and me
personally i like i wanted to build out
a team a system that i could oversee and
not have to be the only one who it was
dependent on to succeed but
but yeah so
the uh
the hiring process i mean i'm no expert
on it i've only been doing it for a few
years now so who knows if i've been
doing it right we'll find out long term
i guess but
my philosophy has kind of always been
[Music]
what i guess the approach i took when i
was working for guys like devin
supertramp which is show me you can add
value show me that you're invested in
what we're doing here and you'll get a
bigger piece of the pie i'm not really
one to say yeah i'll pay you two grand a
month to do this task i like saying show
me that you care about this thing we're
building here and i'll give you a
percentage of it and as it grows you'll
grow with it
and so that's kind of the approach i've
taken with with most of my employees as
we've grown bigger
we've found that okay now we need
someone to do just this little task so
we can pay them just a monthly salary
for that but you know with with the
creators
you know if if they're going to be
invested in in the success of the of the
business and really care about the
content they're putting out that it
succeeds
i personally like to to give them uh
kind of a chunk of what we're doing and
say you know if if it does well you will
do well if it doesn't do well you won't
do well so you can work as hard or as
little as you want but
you'll get compensated accordingly
but
yeah they've
i think all of them
at some point have reached out to me
and pretty much all of them have come
through the full-time filmmaker vine so
it's been students of mine who've taken
my course and said hey i'd love to work
for you and i'd say ah well let me know
what value you can add we'd love to have
you if there's value to be had and
and uh
the first time jake sent me a message he
said all right well here's some work
i've been doing
and it wasn't that good and i said
keep keep working um you're not quite
there it's i don't see a ton of value
and what you can offer but uh you know
keep keep progressing keep working hard
and maybe in the future and about three
months later he had busted his butt
and sent me another video and said hey
check out my latest video and i thought
hey that's actually really good
and he caught my eye and and so i gave
him a chance and so
people who've been persistent with me
who've shown a lot of promise in their
ability to grow and work hard and and
shown that they really are passionate
and really care about what i'm doing and
want to be a part of it
end up being the ones who work for me
it's it's a lot harder
there's plenty of talented people out
there but it's hard to find people that
you know work really hard that have that
work ethic and that care about what
you're doing specifically so that's kind
of what i've looked for is people who
have the talent but also are extremely
hard working and care about what you're
doing and and then it was probably a two
or three year process of molding guys
like jake and landon to the point where
it was like okay
they can crate on their own they don't
need me to micromanage them i trust what
they're doing so it is a process of of
hiring somebody to to recreate your
craft as an artist as a youtuber
it's it's hard to just get someone to
come in and do exactly what you do when
they do things a little bit different
and ideally they bring in things that
you you don't do and add value in ways
you can't
but there does have to be some synergy
and some
brand connectivity between you guys and
so trying to get everyone on the same
page to create in similar ways does take
time but
the investment has been worth it so far
it's freed up my life they've been a
huge blessing to me and
you know allowing the business to
continue grow without me having to
shoulder the the
most of the load
man a lot of insights there and i'm
excited to get into some of your tips
for those that should package what they
know into online courses but a huge
insight was
that
you first put in the hard work and you
bootstrapped and you built this thing
which started to gather a community and
then outside of that out of that
community you met jake and you met some
of the other people on your team and
it's interesting because the same is
true with you know our core of course is
called video reiki academy and tony
ariola who's now full time has
progressed at our company he's like our
uh we call him executive producer
because he fully has absorbed our whole
system titles thumbnails positioning
you know influencing thumbnails you know
click through rate uh and we're at about
10 uploads a week across channels so
there's a lot to produce
um and
uh he had joined our course and then he
actually came to an event we do an
annual event um he went through the
course two times so he really wanted to
master it he applied it on his channel
and his wife's plant-based kitchen
channel ranked some videos got some
success got affiliate passive affiliate
income coming in from an airbnb video he
made so he had done a lot of those
things and uh he showed up to one of our
events actually and helped us set up
chairs before uh just for what we were
launching our book and
and um we started to talk and next thing
you know he actually did like a low paid
internship like just a
not you know super low an amount per
hour internship because we were still
kind of at a growth
tension moment but he showed up added
value and now he's created this
leadership position at our our company
and just uh continues to progress so the
the inspiring thing there is i think for
those listening is thinking about
when you're the entrepreneur though when
you're the the builder when you're the
person who's trying to generate all this
stuff like parker
there's those lonely times before the
jake before before the tony ariola
there's the times when it's just you
it's on you and you got to create the
momentum you got to build the thing you
got to get it going um and then it's
like steps and seasons and now that
there is some momentum others can join
and there's some revenue for that and
you you can kind of build so let's take
it back parker though to to that initial
getting things going
you mentioned at the beginning of this
every youtube creator should seriously
consider taking what they know and
creating a digital product creating an
online course what are your first
initial pieces of advice
for identifying maybe what should i talk
about you know what what's my research
and development phase of things
you know even the hosting and whatnot
that could come sure but like even just
what would i package how do i how do i
how do i get started when i maybe
already feel overwhelmed
trying to just maintain uploading
content
continuing to do freelance work working
a part-time or full-time job to keep the
lights on
speak to that beginning stages of uh
doing this right and getting this going
yeah i
i uh
i tell people that
if you've if you've created a following
that's a pretty telltale sign that
there's people willing to buy something
from you
then it's just figuring out what do they
want
and i usually follow the questions what
what questions are they asking what
problems are they having what what can
you solve what value can you add to
their life
and you know as a filmmaking channel
there's people want luts they want to
learn how to color correct people
want to learn you know education how did
you do that there's there's so many
transitions there's so many little
things you could create doesn't even
have to be education per se
that's where i've specialized as
creating education creating courses but
um i recognize so many opportunities to
create little products light leaks i
mean there's just so many things that
you could build around what you do based
on what your
your followers your people who watch
your stuff are asking for or wanting or
or problems they're having and so it's
it's looking for those
those opportunities in the problems and
i think that's something most people
don't intuitively do they see a problem
they're annoyed by it and they spend
their time in the dms trying to help
people with their problems like no no
get out of the dms take note of all your
dms and say okay i've gotten 10 dms on
this one subject clearly it's something
a lot of people struggle with or a lot
of people want to know about instead of
writing out 10 different dms to all
these people saying pretty much the
exact same thing
log all their questions and notes
somewhere and then script out a video
and then put it in a course and and then
send people a link to the answer to that
question and say hey for 50 bucks i i've
i've spent the last week or two
developing this process that covers
exactly what you're looking for
and you'd be surprised most of them will
say awesome great i'm gonna buy that
thank you so much for doing that and so
it's it's mutually beneficial you put
more time into answering their question
effectively instead of just three
minutes in the dms
and you benefit by getting their money
it was shocking to me when i launched
full-time filmmaker i was expecting
refunds i was expecting complaints i was
expecting this isn't good enough
all i got was gratitude people saying
thank you so much for building this this
is gonna change my life this is amazing
and i was like thank me i just made a
hundred grand in a week i should be
thanking all of you it is mutually
beneficial to create something spend
take the extra time
to create something that people can buy
instead of just
answering dms all day that's annoying
for you and it's really not that helpful
for them
take the time to create something that
will actually solve their problems and
then you will actually benefit from
taking the time to do that
one of the big questions people have and
of course uh think media podcasts check
out show notes because you know the fast
track and the smart move is to find a
mentor and of course parker can help and
we'll link to his resources uh in the
description and um show notes but
pricing i mean one two questions people
you know how long should i make my
course what do i give away free versus
what goes in my course or how do i
handle that when i'm creating youtube
content and then and then
how should i price this thing what is
your advice
yeah
i always tell people um
give people what they want and sell them
on what they need
so for example
a cousin of mine was calling he does
personal training fitness stuff
and he's looking to build a course and
he said i just don't know because
everyone wants to know about the
workouts but really the nutrition is
what's most important that's 80 of
losing weight and staying fit
but everyone wants to know about my
workouts and i'm like well i'll tell you
that but you really need to know about
the nutrition and i said
quinn
give them what they want for free
and then say but look this is only 20 of
the equation if you want to actually
lose weight you have to figure out your
diet you got to figure out how to eat
right i built this course that teaches
you how to eat right
and so
you reel them in with what they want and
then you sell them on what they actually
need so that's that's my advice um as
far as what do you put out for free
versus what do you reserve
figure out what people are most
interested in for for filmmaking it's
the gear it's what's the latest camera
oh that canon thing just came out so i
do a comparison or i do a review we talk
about the gear and then at the end of
the video i say okay that was a fun
piece of gear to talk about really cool
technology but guess what if you don't
know how to use it it doesn't make a
difference so if you want to learn how
to actually get good at video
gotta check out full-time filmmakers
we're gonna teach you how to do this
this and this and actually take
advantage of the gear that you have and
so that's kind of my approach with that
pricing wise
i usually tell people to charge more
than you think
that obviously doesn't apply to
everything in every scenario but the
most course creators i find are
undervaluing their knowledge they're not
confident in what they have to offer
and it depends on what you're offering
but if there is an roi to be made if
somebody by taking your course can
benefit in it in a way where they oh
they'll save money in this way or
they'll be able to generate money in
this way by by
uh
by having your knowledge then value
accordingly and recognize man if
somebody can make a six-figure year job
but with my knowledge then it's worth
more than thirty dollars on udemy don't
don't throw out your
people when they see that in my opinion
when people see a ten dollar udemy class
they think huh they don't even value
their own knowledge why should i and i
found as well that when you price it
a little bit more substantially people
are actually invested in what they
bought if they spent ten dollars on it
it's just like uh if i get to it i'll
get to it and they don't actually value
what you're what you're teaching in that
versus if you charge a hundred dollars
they're going to take the time to
actually dive into it and consume it
well because they invested in it and in
my opinion you'll also filter out some
of those those
i call them the needier students are
usually the ones who
aren't as invested who got a really good
deal or whatever
when they don't pay as much they're not
as invested in it in putting in the time
to learn it and they're going to be more
you know asking you questions over email
and customer service because they're
they're generally just going to be
lazier because they didn't invest in it
so they're going to take more of your
time and so i that's my approach anyway
as i charge a little bit more it is
going to cut out some of the people who
can't afford that but
generally those are going to be a little
bit lazier learners who aren't willing
to invest in themselves
and so you know there's there's pros and
cons in different ways to price but i'm
usually on the
end of recommending a little bit higher
tickets and filtering out some of the
people who aren't going to invest in the
education
what does it
feel like now because you're years into
doing the work congratulations number
three you have two kids number three is
on the way
um you had mentioned years ago you're
like i i wanted to to start a family
and recognized especially when i was on
the grind traveling doing the filming
work and uh
and so you've been very intentional to
to honor your values and build a
business that's also around your
lifestyle um there's no question it
takes a ton of work and you put that
work in but it also has created leverage
because now you have assets something
you've created once that you can
continue to sell
what does it feel like and what is
what kind of encouragement do you have
for those to uh
to maybe
hone their vision of what's possible in
the future on the other side of of doing
the hard work of figuring out your
course and figuring out pricing and
maybe having a webinar or two or ten not
work until you really dial in your offer
um but but what is it what is uh this
business model kind of afforded you
today
it's in a word
freeing i i feel free i feel like i'm in
control of my own life
i also tell anyone who's trying to be an
entrepreneur that while being free
you're also tied to your business if you
want it to be successful as the owner
you you're the one that has to get up
late at night if there's a an immediate
problem that needs to be attended to but
you know ultimately
um it's completely changed my life when
we first started my wife and i i i sat
her down and i said
are you willing to sacrifice right now
so that we can live the way that nobody
else can
in five years from now and she agreed to
that and so that's where we're at now
five years later we are living a life
that most people can't because we are
willing to live a life that nobody's
willing to when we first got married
and so
absolutely the sacrifice was worth it
we paid for it um our our relationship
it was it was great but our first when
we had our first baby
um i was kind of
i mean i was i was present but
always in the head of the business
always thinking about things and
and i remember lex always going over to
her you know in-law or sorry her my
in-laws her mom's house because she
didn't have the emotional support she
needed from me because i was so consumed
in building this business and
and then by the time i got out of the
grind then i was ready to spend more
time with the family
i found that she was in these weird
habits of always going to her mom's
house and i'm like why are we going over
here and she's like well this is how
i've lived the past two years and it
kind of hit me i'm like oh wow i guess i
really haven't been as
attentive as i should have been and and
so it there there are cons to that and
we've had to kind of re-figure out how
to balance work and and family but now
that we've had it figured it out and
have a better balance
it it's just an amazing feeling to know
that the work paid off and and like you
mentioned it it's
the the amount of webinar variations i
had to go through to get one to work was
probably 15 over four or five months
before we got one ad to work to one
webinar to one landing page to actually
generate sales and those are months most
people just aren't willing to put in but
if you're willing to grind and problem
solve and pivot i always tell people to
pivot don't just quit when this doesn't
work make a pivot and go this way that
didn't work make a pivot go that way
until you finally get something to work
and and that's just
it's just something that most people
aren't willing to do i'm not that much
more talented or skilled than most
people on the planet i just have a lot
of confidence in myself and a lot of
hard work that i put in that and i know
if i just keep pivoting and keep trying
new things eventually something's going
to work and so
um believe in yourself have a little bit
of confidence i i always say fake it
till you make it which basically means
um do things you're not comfortable with
do things you're not confident will work
out until they eventually work out
because you've tried so many variation
that that one is bound to work
um but
yeah life life is is amazing for us and
uh we couldn't be happier we feel
immensely blessed and
now we're out of such we're now we're
now in a situation where we feel this
giant need to now give back and you know
offer people jobs and we're starting
charities and it's it's a cool position
to be in in a different
uh responsibility now that we feel a
burden we feel now to to give back now
that we've been so immensely blessed and
so
um you know if that's where you want to
be someday in a position where you're
trying to figure out how to give what
you have instead of figuring out how to
get something then put in the work
and i really appreciate you sharing that
and you know what's interesting is we
have been on different trajectories but
somewhat similar because in 2015
is when um i actually transitioned out
of all freelance work i was doing social
media management video production
managing people's youtube channels and
just into
focusing on my own content and then
building our first course so it's really
been the last five six years that think
media has gone become like a full-time
thing and really been
been building what it is but um it was
only in the last year as we are
recording this
my
first son sean bradley's birthday is
just a few days away his first birthday
and um i can't even imagine
actually trying to uh to what what the
last year has been like
uh maybe during the climb because it was
crazy especially first two three years
of of uh trying to do everything because
you're trying to make you're trying to
do the front end marketing while also
trying to build the course keep the
course updated while also trying to
think about hiring and get help and
doing it all um but it's it's
encouraging to hear because i think that
everybody listening to this we all have
a little bit of a different story you
know and and i feel blessed because
the last year our business has been the
most mature
and so i have had the most margin and i
would say healthy pace um to have that
first child but we can't always plan
those things out and so if you're
listening to this
that's kind of the nature of
entrepreneurship and if you can stay
unified and survive through those
seasons
the vision of what's on the other side
the freedom you now experience the third
is on the way the ability to give back
and and the charitable work you're
starting you know um man entrepreneurs
fight for that brighter future and that
purpose-driven future and so it's
inspiring to hear
about your journey well parker
of course we're going to uh help people
find all the ways they can connect with
your various resources in the show notes
but anything you want to give a shout
out to how can people connect with you
and follow you
um on the social internets
yeah i'd say the main place is just our
youtube channel a
channel is called parker walbeck and uh
go give me a follow there we put out
awesome content like i say lots of free
stuff of what you actually want but not
everything you need and so you may have
to join the course if you want to get
the full i mean we're up to like 500
videos now most people don't even finish
our course anymore because we've built
it out so big but you know there's a lot
of good uh nuggets in there yeah we
focused on a lot of the creative aspects
on our youtube channel so if you're
trying to figure out how to
get good at doing video that's the place
to go we're actually
getting into some challenge videos here
pretty soon um we're gonna start doing
some fun stuff there giving away prizes
and stuff so
yeah go check us out there we're also on
instagram full-time filmmaker is where
to go there i have a personal account as
well but i rarely post there once i
built up my full-time filmmaker
instagram account i felt so relieved i'm
not a big social media guy i've never
liked being on it i don't like being in
front of the camera i don't like
attention i'm kind of introverted but
i've just recognized the opportunity to
build it and once it was built i'm like
okay i can kind of relax from posting
now so you can follow my personal
account parker while back on instagram
but i don't post very much they're
mostly family stuff
awesome i appreciate you sharing that
and i definitely recommend check out the
youtube channel it's next level man i
mean because you guys obviously you've
got this
uh all this kind of
b-roll uh all these shots that are just
absolutely insane and so if you want to
level up to
that uh that next edge as far as your
video production quality slow motion
what's your favorite camera right now
what's your personal favorite gear right
now for the kind of uh content you
create yeah so my go-to right now is
this camera right here which is the c70
canon c70
um
since i've gone more towards
cinema cameras i i'm having a hard time
still liking the image quality from dslr
mirrorless's even though it's almost
indistinguishable i'm just kind of a
camera snob
so the c70s might go to the r5 which is
right here above me actually
see that for that top down
but yeah i was doing some uh top-down
stuff earlier so that's there nice but
yeah the r5 is uh
it's it's like a better for vlogging
kind of smaller footprint and i just
ordered the uh the 8k red raptor
which no i don't need it but amazing and
yes
and it's mostly a
high-end cinema camera that we use to
compare to iphones it's the main value
we get out of that but
yeah i'm a canon guy uh i do love red
cameras but they're big and clunky so
there's kind of a camera for everything
did just buy the iphone this morning i
actually shoot probably 70 or 80 of my
videos you know mostly a family and
stuff from the iphone just because it's
always in your pocket so and i always
tell people too like man iphones are so
good nowadays that don't you don't have
to buy a camera to get started just turn
your iphone on and start creating
content and as you grow go you know buy
bigger and better gear i'm about to
pre-order the iphone did you go 13
promax one terabyte apple care
no one terabyte i got the uh half
terabyte because i use icloud so i don't
actually need that much space but
got the got the max pro and the pro
because the pro
comes two weeks sooner than the max and
so i figured i'll create some content
with the pro and i mean creating
actually
yeah smart well uh parker appreciate you
so much thanks for coming on the think
media podcast thanks for having me sean
appreciate you
wow what an interview i'm so excited
that parker made it on the think media
podcast so we could bring his knowledge
to the community i think it's so
encouraging to see that you know he
started as a content creator really he
started because he didn't even like his
job and now he's grown this amazing
company now online courses was the thing
that helped him get to where he is today
and if you want to get started with an
online course you can go to
createwiththink.com
to get your first month free with
thinkific you can actually sign up for
their free plan or upgrade to other
plans and when you do that i created a
free video over on our youtube channel
if you're watching here it's just a few
videos back if you're listening on the
podcast definitely go to the think media
podcast channel where you're going to
see a how to create an online course
that sells step-by-step free tutorial
that i created for those who are ready
to get started with their online courses
now here at think media we've created
several successful online courses we
built a multiple seven-figure media
company around our online courses so i'm
sharing with you the knowledge that
we've put into practice over the last
half decade as we've been creating and
refining our process for making great
online courses so createwithink.com is
where you'd want to go if you want to
get started with that free trial but i
want to just encourage you to get
started in whatever your next action
step is maybe you're just starting your
youtube channel or maybe you've been at
this for a while and you're ready to go
all in
maybe creating that course is the right
thing for you but i want you to take
action on your next step so if you're
listening over on apple podcast rate and
review the podcast and let me know what
are your action steps for this year and
if you're over on the youtube channel
let me know in the comment section below
what is your next step after listening
to today's episode now if you are one of
our family members over on the youtube
channel you've subscribed and left a
comment you might be featured on an
upcoming episode today i'm featuring
cheryl who commented on the how to
create an online course that sells video
and she said thank you heather i'm a
yoga and meditation teacher and i hope
to offer my first online course in 2022.
we'll bookmark this video and get to
work on it cheryl i hope that you get to
that course this year i cannot wait to
see
all the impact that you make when you
actually package your knowledge into a
course and put it out for the world to
buy it's so important that you know that
youtube is just the start of the whole
journey of building your online business
and you can do this i've seen so many
content creators start on youtube and
grow a successful online business that's
making an impact in the world and that
could be you too as well cheryl thank
you so much for being a part of today's
episode thank you to thinkific for
sponsoring today's episode and i cannot
wait for all of the content that we have
for you in the future here on the think
media podcast i'll catch you in an
upcoming episode bye